un tel instinct peut avoir des conséquences concrètes,
car la première chose que j'ai découverte, c'est que je ne suis pas la seule.
En 2007, le Washington Post a publié un reportage sur l'armée américaine
qui faisait des essais avec un robot détonateur de mines antipersonnel.
Le robot avait la forme d'un phasme.
Il marchait dans les champs de mines
et chaque fois qu'une de ses pattes en touchait une, elle explosait.
Le robot continuait de chercher d'autres mines sur ses pattes restantes.
Le colonel responsable de cet essai
a fini par arrêter le programme,
car, selon lui, c'était trop inhumain
d'observer le robot endommagé se traîner dans les champs de mines.
Qu'est-ce qui peut bien susciter chez un militaire endurci
et quelqu'un comme moi
une telle réaction vis-à-vis des robots ?
Il est vrai que nous sommes poussés par la science-fiction et la culture pop
à concevoir de l'anthropomorphisme pour ces objets.
Mais c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça.
En fait, nous sommes biologiquement conçus pour projeter intention et vie
dans toutes les choses animées dans notre espace physique qui paraissent autonomes.
Dès lors, on traite toutes sortes de robots comme s'ils étaient vivants.
On donne des noms aux engins de déminage
et on leur remettait des médailles.
Ils ont même eu des funérailles avec salve d'honneur.
Les recherches éclairent le fait que nous agissons ainsi avec nos robots ménagers
comme l'aspirateur Roomba.
(Rires)
C'est un simple disque qui déambule sur le sol pour le nettoyer,
mais le seul fait de se mouvoir autours de nous
incite les gens à lui donner un nom
et à ressentir de la peine pour le Roomba quand celui-ci est coincé.
(Rires)
On peut concevoir des robots précisément pour susciter cette réaction,
en utilisant des yeux et un visage ou des mouvements
que les gens vont automatiquement associer inconsciemment
à des états d'esprit.
Il y a un champ de recherche entier, l'interaction humains - robots,
qui explique ces mécanismes.
Par exemple, des chercheurs de l'Université de Stanford ont découvert
que ça met les gens très mal à l'aise
quand on leur demande de toucher les parties intimes d'un robot.
(Rires)
De ces réactions, et d'autres recherches,
nous savons que les gens réagissent à des indices qui leur sont tendus
par ces engins mimant la vie,
même quand ils savent que ces engins ne sont pas vivants.
Notre avenir sera rempli de robots.
La technologie robotique est en train de sortir des usines.
Elle intègre le lieu de travail, le domicile.
Alors que ces machines autonomes qui peuvent sentir,
prendre des décisions et apprendre, intègrent notre environnement de vie,
je pense que la meilleure analogie à disposition
est notre relation avec les animaux.
Il y a des milliers d'années, on a domestiqué les animaux
et on les a entraînés au travail, à la guerre et à devenir nos compagnons.
Durant l'histoire, on a traité certaines bêtes comme des outils ou des marchandises
et on a traité d'autres animaux avec affection,
on leur a donné une place dans la société en tant que compagnons.
Je pense plausible que nous commencions à intégrer les robots de la même manière.
Certes, les animaux sont vivants.
Les robots ne le sont pas.
Et mon expérience avec des ingénieurs en robotique me permet d'affirmer
qu'on est loin de concevoir des robots qui ressentent quoi que ce soit.
Mais nous éprouvons des sentiments à leur égard
et c'est crucial.
Car si nous tentons d'intégrer des robots dans nos espaces de vie,
il faut comprendre qu'on ne va pas les traiter comme d'autres objets
et que dans certains cas,
par exemple, celui du soldat qui s'est attaché affectivement
au robot avec lequel il travaille,
ça peut devenir improductif, voire dangereux.
Dans d'autres cas toutefois, ça peut être utile
de nourrir une connexion émotionnelle avec un robot.
Il y a des usages fabuleux,
comme par exemple les robots qui travaillent avec des enfants autistes.
Ils créent un lien avec eux jamais constaté auparavant.
Il y a aussi des robots aux côtés des enseignants
pour pousser, avec succès, les enfants à apprendre.
Il n'y a pas que les enfants.
Des études montrent que les robots peuvent assister médecins et infirmières
dans le milieu des soins de la santé.
PARO est un robot bébé phoque.
Il est utilisé dans des maisons pour patients atteints de démence.
Ça fait déjà un certain temps.
Je me souviens d'une soirée, il y a des années,
où j'avais parlé de ce robot à quelqu'un.
Et cette personne avait réagi ainsi :
« Oh mon dieu !
C'est horrible.
Je ne peux pas croire qu'on donne aux gens des robots à la place d'attention. »
C'était une réaction habituelle
et qui est correcte, je pense,
car en effet, ce serait terrible.
Dans ce cas, le robot ne remplace pas l'homme.
C'est de la thérapie animale
dans un contexte où on ne peut pas utiliser des animaux.
Mais on peut utiliser des robots
car les gens vont les traiter davantage comme un animal que comme un robot.
Reconnaître cette connexion émotionnelle aux robots
peut aussi nous aider à anticiper les défis
liés au fait que ces engins intègrent les espaces intimes de nos vies.
Par exemple, serait-il acceptable que le robot nounours de votre enfant
enregistre des conversations privées ?
Serait-il tolérable que votre robot sexuel ait une fonction d'achat attractive ?
(Rires)
Car robots plus capitalisme
égalent les questions sur la protection du consommateur et la vie privée.
Ce ne sont pas les seules raisons
pour lesquelles nos comportements avec ces engins sont importants.
Quelques années après ma première expérience
avec le robot bébé dinosaure,
j'ai organisé un atelier avec mon ami Hannes Gassert.
On a pris cinq robots bébés dinosaures
que l'on a remis à cinq équipes.
Elles devaient leur donner un nom,
jouer avec et interagir avec eux pendant une heure environ.
Ensuite, on leur a remis un marteau et une hache
et on leur a demandé de torturer et tuer les robots.
(Rires)
La situation est devenue beaucoup plus tendue
que ce que nous avions pensé
car aucun participant n'a voulu faire de mal
aux robots bébés dinosaures.
Du coup, on a dû improviser et leur dire ceci :
« D'accord. Vous pouvez sauver votre robot si vous détruisez celui des autres. »
(Rires)
Même ça, ça n'a pas marché. Ils n'y arrivaient pas.
Alors on leur a dit :
« On va détruire tous les robots
si personne n'en casse un à la hache. »
Alors, un type s'est levé et a pris la hache.
Toute l'assemblée a grimacé quand il l'a abattue
sur le cou du robot.
Un silence s'est installé dans la salle, mi-sérieux, mi-plaisanterie,
pour le robot tombé.
(Rires)
C'était une expérience vraiment intéressante.
Ce n'était pas une expérience contrôlée
mais elle a mené à des recherches ultérieures au MIT
que j'ai conduites avec Palash Nandy et Cynthia Breazeal.
Nous invitions des gens dans le labo pour écraser ces HEXBUGs
qui se meuvent très réalistement, comme des insectes.
Au lieu de choisir des objets mignons qui attirent les gens,
on a choisi quelque chose de plus basique.
Nous avons découvert que les gens avec une grande empathie
hésitaient davantage à frapper les HEXBUGs.
C'est une petite étude
qui fait partie d'un grand champ de recherches
qui semble indiquer qu'il pourrait y avoir un lien
entre les tendances pour l'empathie des gens
et leur comportement avec des robots.
Ma question cruciale pour l'ère prochaine d'interactions hommes - robots
n'est pas : « Ressentons-nous de l'empathie pour les robots ? »
C'est : « Les robots peuvent-ils changer l'empathie des gens ? »
Y a-t-il une bonne raison pour, par exemple,
empêcher votre enfant de frapper un robot-chien,
non pas pour le respect des biens,
mais parce que ça pourrait le rendre plus susceptible de frapper un vrai chien ?
À nouveau, il n'y a pas que les enfants.
C'est le débat des jeux vidéo violents, mais à un tout autre niveau,
à cause de cette réaction physique et viscérale plus intense
que celle ressentie face à des images sur écran.
Si nous agissons avec violence vis-à-vis des robots,
des robots conçus pour imiter la vie,
est-ce un exutoire sain des comportements violents
ou bien est-ce en train de nourrir notre cruauté ?
On ne sait pas.
Toutefois la réponse peut influencer les comportements humains,
elle peut influencer les normes sociales,
elle peut inspirer des règles sur ce qu'on peut et ne peut pas faire
avec certains robots,
à l'instar des lois contre la cruauté envers les animaux.
Même si les robots ne ressentent pas,
notre comportement à leur égard est important pour nous-mêmes.
Que nous changions ou pas nos réglementations,
les robots pourraient nous offrir une compréhension nouvelle de nous-mêmes.
Tout ce que j'ai appris ces dix dernières années,
ne concerne pas la technologie.
Il s'agit de la psychologie de l'homme,
de l'empathie et de la façon dont nous nous lions avec autrui.
Car quand un enfant est gentil avec Roomba,
qu'un soldat tente de sauver un robot sur le champ de bataille
ou qu'un groupe de personnes refuse d'abîmer un robot bébé dinosaure,
ces robots ne sont plus que des moteurs, des engrenages et des algorithmes.
Ils deviennent le reflet de notre propre humanité.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)